we come now to the Award for Best  Supporting Actor those in contention or  fellows who played a juvenile delinquent  or not see a gangster a gambler and the  pool muscle now you know why I turned  down the title role in the story of  Albert Schweitzer Roz Russell is going  to play to present this award here's  last year's Oscar winner for Best  Supporting Actress miss shirley jones  huh surely why is it that you and I have  never made a picture together Oh Bob you  know that old saying you can't win them  all yes you can't lose them all even  I've come close the nominees for Best  Performance by an actor in a supporting  role are George Chakiris in West Side  Story  Montgomery Clift in judgment at  Nuremburg Peter Falk in pocketful of  miracles Jackie Gleason in the hustler  George see Scott in the hustler and the  winners name is in this envelope  the winner is George Chakiris  I don't think I'll try and talk too much  I just want to say thank you very very  much thank you